[Musica]
allora iniziamo con un piccolo aneddoto
un personale che io ho riportato non vi
riporto più in quale dei libri ma che è
molto importante nella storia di cui
stiamo parlando
io avevo 29 anni lavoravo in azienda
facevo un tratto come spiegato
addirittura come freelance che era il
nome carino che negli anni ottanta si
dava i precari perché negli anni 80 ci
davamo tutti abbastanza un tono e e poi
ero diventato impiegato poi dopo
impiegato più specializzato un po il
quadro è addirittura a 29 anni sono
diventato dirigente mi ero prefissato di
arrivarci a 30 quindi ricordo il giorno
in cui tornando dalla stanza
dell'amministratore delegato con in mano
questa lettera ho percorso il corridoio
sono entrato nella mia stanza e mi sono
seduto e ho riletto questa lettera di
cui conosceva naturalmente il contenuto
che mi nominava dirigente
io ricordo preciso della sensazione che
provare che non era affatto una
sensazione univoca è una sensazione
meticcia da un lato era ovviamente
soddisfatto è il mio padre aveva fatto
un percorso aziendale analogo quindi
qualche modo mi rispecchiavo nella sua
carriera e nero molto soddisfatto di
essere riuscito nell'intento che mi ero
prefissato ma naturalmente non trovarmi
in una condizione di perfetta sintonia
di perfetto benessere mi ha subito
insospettito avrei dovuto come tutti
quelli che sono dire pienamente nel
luogo dove devono essere e fanno quello
che si sente di dover fare avrei dovuto
compiacermi con me stesso provare un
grande piacere e l'istante dopo fissare
nuovamente un uomo obiettivo così fanno
gli ambiziosi io ero un ambizioso ero
uno che voleva crescere voleva imparare
voleva fare strada
invece io ho provato una sensazione
molto forte molto chiara che li berlino
sono riusciti a decodificare ma che poi
col tempo ho capito essere
la certezza che non avrei fatto quello
tutta la vita cioè nel momento in cui
dovevo accettare nuovamente l'asticella
ho pensato che quello sport non era una
cosa che avrei fatto per tutto il tempo
questa sensazione si è diciamo così
allignato si è radicata nella mia mente
nel mio cuore io ho continuato per il
mio lavoro con molto impegno con molta
partecipazione le cose sono andate bene
sono stato fortunato ho fatto buone cose
era un periodo in cui io lavoravo nel
mondo della comunicazione e le cose
andavano bene sono stato bravo mi sono
impegnato lo sono stato anche molto
fortunato ho avuto buoni maestri però le
cose in un certo senso sono rimaste lì
appeso e quella sensazione è rimasta
dentro di me
e c'è un altro aneddoto che in qualche
modo chiude il cerchio tra due
sensazioni che si sono richiamate tra
loro hanno determinato un azione è stato
molti anni dopo ero sul raccordo anulare
di roma viveva la roma all'epoca erano
le sette e mezza di mattina eravamo già
chiusi tutti dentro la loro macchinetta
ognuno quei telefonini accesi faceva
molto caldo era il 4 luglio per curiosa
coincidenza
e quel giorno mi sono detto così non va
non posso vivere tutta la vita così non
posso uscire quando tutti escono non
posso tornare quando tutti tornano non
posso fare le cose che fanno tutti non
voglio vivere secondo schemi che sono
stati fissati da qualcun altro un che
sono diciamo il risultato di una norma
che si è affermata come la prioritaria
la vincente quella omologazione
quell'essere tutti nella stessa
circostanza mi è sembrata insopportabile
e allora sono uscito dall'autostrada
appena ho potuto dal raccordo anulare
che è una specie di autostrada e mi
ricordo ho cercato per le vie di un
posto che non conoscevo perché era una
zona di roma
dove non riuscivo mai ho cercato un bar
che avesse una pergola possibilmente
potendo stare fuori all'ombra preso un
caffè e mi sono seduto al tavolino con
l'idea di studiare una soluzione che non
avevo però io sapevo fare e ci voleva
tutta che lo sapessi fare solo quello
che facevo non avevo un piano b non
avevo una soluzione non avevo pensato ad
altro e ricordo che quel giorno mi sono
preso un pezzo di carta una penna mi
sono messo a ragionare o mi sono messo a
fare la sua analisi tutti i manager
presenti sanno cos'è quella roba per cui
tu fai una serie di colonne menti quello
che hai quello che non hai quello che ti
serve quello che dovresti avere per fare
quello che vorresti farlo e la colonna
delle cose che mi servivano era molto
ricca quelle che avevo erano poche erano
buone per fare quello che avevo sempre
fatto ma non oltre
e da quel momento ho iniziato a lavorare
ho iniziato a lavorare o un progetto che
era un progetto di liberazione
diciamo così di audit di autenticità di
autenticazione
io ero nato per scrivere e navigare
ognuno di noi è nato per fare una cosa e
tante persone mi scrivono tu sei
fortunato perché tu sai navigare sai sai
scrivere come se io fossi nato col
timone in mano con la penna in mano ma
insomma ovviamente come potete
immaginare non è così io non so fare
niente
questo ovviamente non è vero jack london
diceva una cosa molto bella scriveva che
se che ognuno di noi come una pallina
messa su un piano sfalsato se noi vi
lasciamo quella pallina compie una
traiettoria che se non le rompi l'anima
lungo la via è una certa traiettorie lui
chiamava questa la linea di minore
resistenza cioè quello che noi faremmo
bene
sentendoci bene mentre lo facciamo
se potessimo farlo la mia linea di
minore resistenza in questo sono stato
fortunato mi era abbastanza chiara cioè
io fin da quando ero un bambino
sapevo che sentivo perché poi sapere una
questione che viene con la
consapevolezza ma sentivo che dovevo
scrivere navigare quella era la mia
linea di minore resistenza in quel
momento si compie nella mia vita ho
fatto molto importante dal sapere che
cosa fosse il libero da che è una cosa
molto diffuso ognuno di noi sa cosa vuol
dire libero da libero dal capufficio
libero dai ritmi il libro dagli le
incombenze dalle responsabilità dal peso
sul cuore dai dei mutui dalle relazioni
coatte non scelte da tema da un
direttore del personale che per
definizione un pazzo come sappiamo se ti
ha messo accanto di scrivania uno come
il tuo collega da quella consapevolezza
molto diffusa io acquisivo in quel
momento un'altra consapevolezza che è
quella di che cosa dovevo diventare
libero di che fa parte dell'altra metà
però della faccenda
la gran parte della gente quando parla
di libertà ha chiaro cosa vuol dire
libero da ma non che cosa lui vorrebbe
dovrebbe sente che vorrebbe essere
libero di ho lasciato il lavoro da
allora ho cambiato la mia vita l'ho
cambiata facendo un progetto però
intorno a questo essendo uno scrittore
essendo sempre stato ed essendo poi
divenuto in maniera più professionale
più metodologica un progetto che ha a
che fare con un altro modo per vivere
perché ho scoperto dopo tante paure dal
primo esempio che abbiamo fatto dei 29
anni a quando ho cambiato la mia vita ne
sono passati 12 perché ho dovuto vincere
tutte le paure del caso è dovuto pormi
tutte le domande e trovare una risposta
originale all'epoca di queste cose non
si parlava era
2008 quando ho cambiato la mia vita il
gennaio del 2008 per curiosa coincidenza
per settembre la crisi di lehman
brothers mi provò a dispetto di ogni
eventuale dubbio che avevo fatto bene
da quel momento in avanti il progetto si
è arricchito ed è diventato una cosa che
io potevo avere il coraggio finalmente
di tentare di vivere ero terrorizzato
naturalmente di non avere lo stipendio
sono anche il figlio di una stirpe di
genovesi quindi la faccenda è anche
piuttosto seria e ma soprattutto ero
terrorizzato di interrompere una
carriera era arrivato in una buona
posizione per me per i miei mezzi e
sapevo che dai 40 anni in poi avrei
potuto raccogliere tutto quello che
avevo seminato il mestiere che si chiama
relazioni pubbliche ci vuole parecchio
per costruirle queste relazioni però
dopo producono i loro frutti facevo
comunicazione relazioni pubbliche
eccetera
tutto quello che sarebbe venuto dopo io
non lo avrei vissuto quindi lo stavo
perdendo la paura di perdere quello che
si ha
mi sono reso conto con il tempo era il
freno maggiore perché non c'era
coscienza di tutto quello che non avrei
avuto se non avessi tentato questa è una
cosa molto importante
gli anni che sono seguiti sono stati più
felici della mia vita naturalmente come
facile immaginare perché sono vissuto
facendo esattamente ciò per cui sono
nato sono vissuto tentando di essere ciò
che io sapevo di poter essere e ciò che
sapevo di dover tentare
naturalmente per fare questo il progetto
sia dovuto particolare bene in una serie
di cose molto concrete
dal gennaio del 2008 a oggi ho speso
74mila euro overall quello vissuto con
8.500 euro all'anno circa
ma si può fare molto di più la media
risente dei primi anni in cui ero
poco abituato una casa dove vivo una
casa di pietra un fienile della fine del
seicento che sono anche figo se lo dice
una ragazza che però ristrutturato tutto
da me questa parte meno in cui è
meglio non coinvolge della ragazza che
aveva mai fatto un tetto di una casa di
legno di pietra e poi il tetto di legno
nessuno naturalmente bene anche io
il che si è tragicamente visto il primo
inverno quando avevo 36 vie d'acqua nel
tetto
ho dormito con la cerata integrale meno
male che hanno attrezzato con la goccia
sulla spalla che veniva giù
avevo dimenticato di mettere la carta
catramata pensando che la pendenza
bastasse è sola di errori ne ho fatti
tanti
ho assolutamente compreso però che una
persona che fa la vita che fa ognuno di
noi ogni giorno così complicata a tutte
le risorse per mettersi di fronte ai
problemi e tentare di risolverli in
maniera molto creativa volta in maniera
anche un po fallimentare ma comunque
molto soddisfacente ho scoperto che si
può avuto produrre la gran parte delle
cose che ci servono
io mi faccio ammazzare piuttosto che
comprare qualcosa questo il fatto di
essere di origine genovese aiuta ma ma
ma non basta bisogna anche un po
inventarsi le cose qua giusto ogni cosa
che che mi serve di di utilizzare o di
riutilizzare considero una specie di
morte interiore quando un
elettrodomestico non lo posso aggiustare
lo devo cambiare però in tutto questo
c'è una grande possibilità è
assolutamente possibile vivere
diversamente assolutamente possibile
anzi necessario uscire dalla
collocazione del pensiero uscire dall
omologazione degli stili di vita perché
il primo abbiamo sentito prima una cosa
molto interessante di un attivista per i
diritti umani
quella è una questione davvero
importante no aiutare le persone ad
essere più sane a vivere di più eccetera
ma c'è qualcosa che io credo
profondamente
che viene prima di quello quello lo
fanno gli eroi quello lo fanno le
persone speciali molti di noi potrebbero
farlo certamente ma sono sicuro che sia
una cosa veramente oltre l'asticella per
tanti di noi ma c'è una cosa che invece
tutti noi possiamo fare ed è quello di
contribuire alla società cercando di
vivere in maniera autentica cercando di
essere davvero quello che si è nati per
essere smettendo di fingere nel fare
mestieri che non ci appartengono che
spesso e volentieri sono dannosi per la
società
smettendo di avere 29 gradi in casa casa
mia si riscalda soltanto con la legna
che io spacco brucio se lasci le
sigarette sul divano a fine ottobre
ricomincia a fumare a marzo perché
chiaramente non ti per allontanare dal
camino però insomma come dire questo
punto alto contribuisce all'abbattimento
dei costi
però insomma adesso parte le battute che
si possono fare davvero tantissime cose
tantissime cose molto molto molto
semplici molto alla nostra portata che
rendono la nostra vita terribilmente
avventurosa senza che poi andiamo a
vedere into the wild c mozioni amo per
quello che vediamo lo possiamo vivere
noi anche senza quegli eccessi e
soprattutto iniziato a fare davvero
quello che sentivo di voler fare di
poter fare che a scrivere navigare posso
essere d'aiuto la società con quello che
scrivo e la mia ricerca dell'autenticità
determinare qualcosa di valore perché ho
intorno per chi può leggere qualcosa di
interessante per chi può
trovare una soluzione attraverso un
esempio una testimonianza questo è
senz'altro una cosa che va fatta
certamente quando quello che facciamo se
lo scriviamo su un foglio è troppo
diverso i segni sono troppo diversi dai
segni che abbiamo addosso forse quello
che stiamo scrivendo non è letteratura
ma è solo finzione e questa è una cosa
che dovremmo ricordarci ci vuole una
certa consistenza e una certa identità
tra quello che facciamo e quello che
diciamo che spesso non c'è
[Applauso]